conservative state legislators are
making a new push to limit abortion
rights and Hollywood is fighting back
actress Alyssa Milano just proposed a
sex strike in response to a recent wave
of state laws restricting or abolishing
abortion Milano posted this tweet asking
women to give up sex until they have
legal control of their bodies now some
critics say that would turn women into
objects at least 5 major movie
production companies say they will stop
producing films in Georgia where an
anti-abortion bill was signed into law
last week Jan Crawford is tracking this
new campaign by abortion opponents Jan
good morning we're talking morning we're
talking about a number of abortion cases
across the country but if the Supreme
Court takes up an abortion case what are
the chances they could overturn Roe vs.
Wade
well I mean let's get that out of the
way right out the front I mean I think
it's very very slim that this new
conservative Supreme Court is going to
overturn Roe vs. Wade at this point
these state laws are just coming too
fast and they're too extreme what you're
seeing is that since the court now does
have that more solid conservative
majority a lot of these Republican
states are passing these highly
restrictive abortion laws and in some
cases almost outright bans hoping that
this new court will allow them and
eventually overturn Roe versus Wade
Alabama lawmakers are scheduled to
continue debating and will probably pass
what will be the strictest anti-abortion
rights law in the country it would ban
abortions at every stage of pregnancy
doctors could face years in prison for
violating it the only exception is if
there's a serious risk to the mother's
health rape and incest not an exception
now this comes after Mississippi Ohio
Kentucky and like you said just last
week Georgia already have passed bills
banning abortions once a fetal heartbeat
is detected
now that's usually about six weeks into
a pregnancy before many women even know
they're pregnant now by comparison Roe
versus Wade and subsequent court rulings
say states can't ban abortion out right
before the fetus is viable outside the
womb that's usually at about 24 weeks
now none of these recently passed
heartbeat bills have gone into effect
yet and there
all facing or will face legal challenges
supporters of the anti abortion rights
measures say those challenges are
exactly what they want because that
could be the path to the Supreme Court a
chance to overturn Roe versus Wade but
at this point those odds I think are
pretty slim Nora yes I just follow up on
that quickly what's the likelihood that
any of these restrictions will make it
to the Supreme Court
well Sienna mean that's the thing they
are so at odds they're so restrictive
with Supreme Court precedent that
they're getting struck down in the lower
courts courts are blocking them from
even taking effect and then when the
lower courts look at them and then look
at the Supreme Court precedent Roe
versus Wade
a 1992 decision Pennsylvania versus
Casey that Casey decision they're
striking them down so these laws may not
ever even get to the Supreme Court like
I said it's almost too much too soon
yeah Jan any reaction to Alyssa Milano's
call for a sex strike why we know I mean
that's Norris said some people were
saying that objectifies women other
people saying well she's advocating
abstinence so maybe that's something
that the abortion opponents would get
behind as well
now here are many women going No thank
you Alyssa yeah thank you very much June